منذ اعوام والعالم يشهد تغير ملحوظا في
نظام العمل والهدف انتاجيه افضل ووقت راحه
اطول في الشارقه تحديدا دراسه تقييميه
شامله اجريت بعد سنه على اعتماد نظام
العمل لاربعه ايام في الاسبوع وكشفت عن
نجاح هذا النظام نتائج الدراسه اظهرت
زياده انتاجيه الموظفين والتواصل ايجابي
بينهم بالاضافه الى ارتفاع نسبه الابتكار
والابداع والتزام بالحضور ومعدل الرضا
الوظيفي نجحوا نظام في الشارقه يتزامن مع
اختباره في بعض الدول الاخرى منها قطر
وفي السعوديه ايضا جاءت مطالبات اعلاميه
بتطبيق النظام كما نشر في مقاله بصحيفه
مكه كاتب المقاله قال ان اعتماد هذا
النظام سيزيد من التصنيفات العالميه
المهمه كقوه ناعمه في تعزيز التواجد على
خارطه العالم
يعني مع اربعه ايام مع اربعه ايام
بتعتقدي انه يزيد الابداعيه والنفسيه وكله
نشوف مع لميس ونرجع
ابرز نتائج دراسه التي قيمت نظام اربعه
ايام عمل وثلاثه ايام اجازه في الشارقه
زياده انتاجات الموظفين بنسبه
88% وواحد التواصل الايجابي بين الموظفين
وابرزت الدراسه ايضا ان الالتزام بالحضور
ارتفع بنسبه 74% وانخفضت الاجازات المرضيه
بنسبه 46% واوضحت الدراسه ان معدل الرضا
الوظيفي والاداء الوظيفي ارتفع بنسبه 90%
وارتفع بنسبه 91% الشعور بالسعاده بشكل
عام وبنسبه 87% التاثير الايجابي في الصحه
النفسيه وفق الدراسه فان نظام يحقق بنسبه
84% التوازن بين الحياه العمليه والاسريه
زياده في الاستمتاع بالعطله الاسبوعيه
و70% زياده نسبه المشاركه في المناسبات
الاجتماعيه واثنين بالمئه زادت الفرصه في
ممارسه الرياضه والهوايات الخاصه
وفيما يخص مستوى متعامل الجهات الحكوميه
اوضحت الدراسه شعور المتعاملين بمعدل رضا
عال عن جوده الخدمات واداء الموظفين بشكل
عام بنسبه 94% على كل حال سال الناس
بالاردن لو حصلت على يوم راحه اضافي في
اسبوعك كيف يمكن ان تستفيد منه نتابع
[موسيقى]
ممكن
والثلث بضل ممكن اروح اطمن على الحجه كوني
متجوز جديد وبعدت عنها من خمسه اشهر ما في
احلى من الواحد يرتاح يكون فيه له راحة
اسبوعيه ممكن يا اما بستغل افراحه في
الدار يا اما بطلع مع واحد من اصدقائي من
واحد من اصحابي بنطلع من شم هوا وبنروح
بنيجي ناخذ اليوم زاهر بالمحبه بالعفويه
[موسيقى]
يعني بصراحه اول شيء بفكر فيني انام في
زياده بعدين اذا في اكتيفيتيز مع اصحابي
اول اشي ممكن اطلع بحس انه اول شيء راح
اخطط لطلعه اني اطلع مع اصحابي انبسط
باليوم وبعمل شوي بس رح استفيد منه بالنوم
راح انام
واذا كان بالصيف بطلع وعادي بس بالشتاء
بنام برد بسحب برد بنام
[موسيقى]
راحوا يوم عطله
راح اقضيهم والنص الثاني اكيد يعني راح
اشوف اهلي راح اطلع انا وخطيبتي سيره زمن
ساعتين زمان
وما كان عندي وقت فهيك يعني اي واحد يتمنى
انه يكون في عنده يوم راحه ولكن لكل عمر
في طريقه معينه للراحه بمعنى انه لما كل
واحد فوق الستين سنه بحب الهدوء بحب اذا
كان في عنده احفاد يقعد معهم فهمت ويغير
جو
[موسيقى]
في الاستوديو تنضم الينا رشا عبد الله
السدحان رئيس تنفيذي للافراد وبيئه العمل
في شركه الامار اهلا بك يسعد صباحك نورتنا
في الاستوديو قبل ما ابلش اسال انا مع
النظام اربعه ايام ولادين ضد فانت بدك
تقنعينا مين صح طيب بالضبط طيب شفنا انه
بعد النجاح في الشارقه يختبر في قطر ويطرح
في السعوديه الى هذا النظام عملي اذا
تسمحي لي بس اقول لك انا ايش رايي ليش بدا
من فنجت فكره هذا النظام اعتقد انه كل
اسلوب العمل تغير بعد الجائحه قبل الجائحه
كان في تركيز شديد انه لازم الموظف جالس
على المكتب قدام اللابتوب يشتغل جت
الجائحه غيرت جميع المفاهيم بعد عن بعد
التقنيات الحديثه فتاكه يعني اذا تقدر
تشتغلي من اي مكان بالعالم وتكون انتاجك
عاليه اعتقد بعد كذا صار في توج وصار عفوا
في تركيز اكثر ووضوح اكثر للصحه النفسيه
وضغوط العمل وتاثير ضغوط العمل على الحياه
وادرك الناس ان العمل لازم ما ياثر بشكل
سلبي على حياتهم فمن هنا بدات الفكره
العديد من الدول عملت هذه التجربه بعضها
اعتقد مده نظري انه الايسلندا عملتها ب
2015 قبل حتى الجائع والدول الثاني اللي
عملتها بريطانيا امريكا استراليا نيوزلندا
وعده دول اخرى كلهم اثبتوا نجاح الدراسه
عملوها ست شهور شافوا الانتاجيه اعلى بشكل
كبير
عدد ايام المرضيه قلت بشكل كبير
شافوا انه الموظفين صاروا اسعد الاستقالات
قلت بشكل كبير بس مثلا انا من الناس اللي
متقاطعيها خليها تقول
الحديث الصوتي انا من الناس اللي بحس مثلا
اذا كثير بعض ثلاثه ايام او هذا نظام
العمل الروتر اللي كنا نعمله
لا بس بفصلني بطريقه سلبيه مش ايجابيه انه
انا بفقد التواصل مع هذا المكان الذي اذهب
للعمل اليه وبالتالي خلص كانه انا بحب
الاستمراريه خلص يكون خمس ايام متواصل
واعرف في عندي يومين بس هاي فقط
والدتي امس كنت اناقشها وقالت نفس الكلام
قالت انه حتى للاطفال في المدارس لما
ياخذوا لونج ويكند يصير صعب عليهم الرجعه
للروتين فهي اكيد تعتمد على الشخصيات بس
وجهه نظرك وجهه نظر يعني
تؤخذ بعيد تؤخذ بعين الاعتبار الجمال بس
السؤال
طيب اليوم كمان انه بما انه هذا يجب انه
يتم تعميمه وفي ناس عم طالب تعميمهم هل
المدراء مدراء الشركات وايضا رؤساء
الاقسام منفتحين على هذا الامر وهذه
المساله وياخذونها بالاعتبار
اعتقد اكثر من اول ايه لانه صارت تقنيات
اسهل
اعتقد انه كمان الجيل الجاي الشباب اللي
في الجامعات والمدارس اعتقد
يفضلو هذا التقنيه اكثر لانهم متعودين انه
الاشياء تخلص بسرعه يقدروا يعملوا اكثر
شيء بنفس الوقت فيمكن هذا يكون مطلب لهم
للجيل القادم لكن كمان احب شويه بس ابين
شويه سلبيات اذا تسمحوا لي لانه ساعات
العمل ما راح تقل فيعني مثلا موظف يشتغل
ثمان ساعات اليوم لمده خمس ايام في
الاسبوع حيصير يعمل عشر ساعات في اليوم
بدل ثمان ساعات في الاسبوع فهذا كمان ممكن
يرهق الموظف انه ساعات العمل اطول لكن
بالمقابل في يوم اجازه اضافه ممكن الوقت
يصير في ضغط اكثر انه يخلص الشغل في اربع
ايام اكثر من خمسه ايام فبالجيكا مؤخرا
عمله
عملوه قانونيا الموظف لو حريه الاختيار
اذا يعمل خمسه ايام او اربع ايام في
الاسبوع الموظف يقدر يختار فهذا يمكن
يناسبك
طيب رشا اللي لفتني نقطه من الابرز
الايجابيات انه موظف او الموظفين يصيروا
اكثر انتاجيه وفعاليه واكثر راحه نفسيه
بهذا النظام الى اي مدى تقنيات الحديثه
مواقع التواصل تساعد على ذلك انه نبقى على
التواصل المرد على التواصل مع العمل حتى
واحنا في البيت
طبعا التقنيات الحديثه سهلت يعني احنا
شفنا في وقت الجائحه الناس تشتغل عبر
القارات على على الزوم ولا على التيمز على
المكالمات الايميلات ما عاد ضروري وجود
الشخص في المكان لكن كمان عدم وجود الشخص
في المكان وعدم وجود بيئه العمل هذه كمان
تسبب شويه فتور يمكن في في الحماس او
الشعور بالانتماء لمنظمه عمل معينه بس رشا
انا كمان يعني بشوف من ضمن السلبيات للعمل
اربعه اربعه ايام وثلاثه ايام في البيت
انه خصوصا للمراه المتزوجه والمراه اللي
عندها اولاد يعني انت لما تروحي على العمل
هو منفس لالك من الزوج ومن الاولاد في
البيت هذا اولا بس هل سيؤخذ مساله الراتب
بعين الاعتبار يعني اللي بيشتغل اربعه غير
اللي بيشتغل خمسه السؤال ممتاز وهو من
قائمه السلبيات اللي انا اللي حضرتها في
بعض الشركات حتقلل الرواتب وفي بعض
الشركات قللت ساعات العمل بتزيد لا هم عاد
يسووها بحسبه معينه يخلوها مش نفس عدد
ساعات العمل الاسبوعي حيقللوها وهيقللوها
وفي شركات ثانيه لا يعني ممكن الراتب يقل
هل بتضلي على كلامك انه انت مستعده تداومي
اربعه ايام مع راتب اقل شكرا جزيلا استديو
رشا عبد الله السدحان رئيس التنفيذي
الافراد وبيئه العمل وشركه القمر نورتي
شكرا جزيلا شكرا